people around the country would say this
is what they needed to Humble themselves
we wasn't arrogant or whatever we just
we're confident people if our confidence
defends your insecurity that's the
problem with you it's not us and we
expect to do well we expect to play well
we expect to win every game we step out
there we expect to practice to
Perfection and go out there and execute
the things that we practice we just
didn't do it today it's not something
that was needed it's just like saying
you get in a car wreck or something oh
he needed that to slow him down you
don't need that it's just stupid it's
just something that happened and we they
got the best of us today that's just it